sí
[Aplausos]
el rey midas en rey midas fue un rico y
poderoso monarca de la región de frisia
midas el amigo del dios baco y éste
quiso concederle un deseo porque había
sido bueno y benevolente con uno de sus
súbditos enseguida supo qué es lo que
quería quiero convertir en oro todo lo
que toque
más pronto que tarde medida supo que
éste no había sido buen deseo porque iba
a convertirse en el hombre más rico del
mundo sí pero el hombre más rico del
mundo iba a morir de hambre el hombre
más rico del mundo iba a morir de sed
porque los alimentos se volvían de oro
cuando les tocaba
y el momento más trágico en la historia
del rey midas vino cuando su hija quiso
consolarlo y él acabó abrazando a una
bonita estatua de oro
por suerte esta historia tiene un final
más feliz pero la solemos utilizar para
transmitir una moraleja y es que la
avaricia trae muy malas consecuencias
está pues una explicación de cuáles son
las causas por las que medias acaba esa
manera pero hoy no nos la vamos a creer
vamos a quedarnos sólo con lo que
sabemos de verdad de la historia del rey
midas uno medidas tienen suman un poder
tiene una herramienta casi ilimitada el
dios el deseo que le permite el dios
midas pide un deseo que se cumple de
forma literal
y tres al cumplirse de forma literal el
deseo me das obtiene un final que no era
el que esperaba
y porque os cuento esta historia hemos
venido aquí a hablar del futuro pues
porque la historia del rey midas tiene
mucho mucho que ver con el siguiente
titular
amazon creo
una inteligencia artificial para
intentar contratar a un empleado al que
más ajustará al puesto de trabajo y que
consiguió una herramienta que
discriminaba de forma sistemática a las
mujeres
cómo fue esto se confundieron a hacer el
programa funcionó mal el algoritmo pasó
como cuando se nos estropea un programa
del ordenador
vamos a ponernos en situación imaginad
que somos el equipo de recursos humanos
de amazon los ingenieros tenemos a
nuestra disposición una herramienta la
inteligencia artificial y queremos hacer
este selector de personal cogemos todos
los currículums de nuestros empleados de
los que ya están en la empresa y
entrenamos a la inteligencia artificial
después con los currículums de los
posibles candidatos los ingenieros le
preguntan a la inteligencia artificial
oye cuál es el candidato que más se
ajusta al perfil que hay en mi empresa
de esta forma tendríamos al candidato
ideal no
vamos a recapitular un poco uno amazon
tiene en su mano una herramienta un
poder ilimitado la inteligencia
artificial 2
amazon hace una petición consigue el
mejor empleado pero se cumple de manera
literal escogieron al empleado que más
se ajustaba a las característas a las
características de sus empleados los
cuales la mayoría eran hombres y 3 como
se cumple de manera literal
amazon obtiene un resultado que no
esperaba por suena dar vuestros tres
puntos la historia de medidas y lastra
la historia de amazon son exactamente la
misma tendrán alguna causa en común que
es la avaricia de medidas algún tema
ideológico
alguna teoría así un poco más
conspiranoica
la solución es muy sencilla es un
problema que tiene que ver con la
comunicación es un problema del lenguaje
veréis nosotros los humanos cuando nos
comunicamos queremos transmitir ideas
que están en una mente e intentar
ponerlas en mentes de otras personas y
para eso necesitamos algún vehículo
conductor cuando hacemos transacciones
monetarias cuando intercambiamos dinero
que necesitamos algo físico moneda
billetes de la misma manera necesitamos
algún medio físico para plasmar estas
ideas y poder transmitirlas a los demás
y es ahí donde utilizamos el lenguaje la
palabra el lenguaje hablado
poneros en situación viernes por la
tarde salís de la oficina de trabajar o
de estudiar aquí a la facultad está esta
película que tanto os gusta que llevan
un montón tiempo naciendo en la tele y
queréis ir a verla escribirse un amigo
lee si soy la petición al cine
que sí que tengo muchísimas ganas y si
bien había suerte vamos a ir al cine
vamos a pasar bien vamos a ver esta peli
que tanto deseo pasa con el palomitas
rebobinamos
viernes por la tarde sales de la oficina
sales de trabajar le escribes a tu amigo
porque está esta peli que tanto te
interesa venga que diga que sí que diga
que sí
a él le apetece querido amigo pero es el
mismo mensaje que recibo ahora que el
que he recibido antes pero si la palabra
que me ha dicho el sí es exactamente el
mismo se supone que le apetece pero yo
si a mí me responde en esto digo este no
quiere venir conmigo al cine lo ha dicho
por compromiso ya está no pasa nada que
es lo que ha cambiado de un mensaje a
otro ha sido la palabra no ha sido todo
lo que hay alrededor las exclamaciones
los emoticonos lo que en definitiva
nosotros llamamos contexto nos
comunicamos de una mara contextual
porque somos muy inteligentes y somos
capaces de comunicar decodificar
información más allá de las propias
palabras por eso decimos que los humanos
nos comunicamos de manera contextual
y con quién nos comunicamos con una
máquina un ordenador cómo hablan los
ordenadores
en palabras del creador del software
linux uno de los softwares más
importantes a nivel mundial que
declaraba hace poco en una entrevista lo
que me gusta de trabajar con ordenadores
es que hacen exactamente lo que les
dices y nada más
que hacen exactamente lo que les dices y
nada más
a los ordenadores aunque no lo parezca
no son máquinas muy inteligentes que
saben hacer muchos cálculos y por
supuesto ya habrá una hoja de excel una
hoja de cálculo si digo esto no voy a
poder hacer la vida y esta máquina lo
hace así con arrastrar el ratón debe ser
muy lista pero no solo sabes seguir
instrucciones muy bien es lo único que
saben hacer los ordenadores si tú estás
haciendo un programa y te equivocas en
un paréntesis en el ordenador dice no te
entiendo y en cambio tú como persona
eres capaz de ver perfectamente que hay
falta un paréntesis los ordenadores se
comunican es el ejemplo perfecto de
comunicación textual solo entienden lo
que va a codificado en las instrucciones
pues bien es aquí donde surge el
problema cuando tenemos un interlocutor
el humano que entiende o que piensa que
el ordenador va a ser capaz de entender
toda la información que viaja en el
contexto y al revés que vamos a querer
recibir información en el contexto por
parte del ordenador y es aquí donde
surge un conflicto entre tecnología y
humanos
pero claro si hablamos de conflicto
tecnología y humanos seguro que no me
vais a perdonar si no hablamos de
inteligencia artificial lo que pasa con
la inteligencia artificial es muy
curioso porque -según a quien preguntéis
tiene una multitud de caras seguro que
si vamos aquí a la calle y preguntamos
un poco la opinión general de que es una
inteligencia artificial nos dirán que es
un robot con forma humanoide seguro con
brazos cabeza que es súper inteligente
se va a hacer muchísimas más cosas que
yo y que no mucho tiempo se revelará
contra nosotros y pondrá su supremacía y
'la a los humanos esclavos de la
inteligencia artificial eso es una
opinión muy extendida de lo que es la
inteligencia artificial
pero si cambiamos de foro y vamos tal
vez alguien que está acostumbrado a
trabajar con ella a programarla
seguro que nos dicen que la inteligencia
artificial no es más que un programita
un algoritmo que es capaz de resolver
tareas muy concretas conducir un coche
autónomo
detectar exoplanetas predecir el precio
de las cosas o
diagnostican enfermedades que a nosotros
nos cuesta
la inteligencia artificial no es más que
un programa capaz de hacer problemas muy
sencillos como algunos problemas que nos
llevan atormentando durante mucho tiempo
a los humanos y que ahora somos capaces
de resolver con la inteligencia
artificial
tengo delante un chihuahua
una galleta
esta foto que te enseña es un muffin es
un perro
de veras y es tenéis que ir con una
imagen de qué es la inteligencia
artificial se parece muchísimo más a un
programa de ordenador que casi siempre
es capaz de diferenciar un perro de una
galleta se parece mucho más a esto que a
un robot asesino
de verdad un programa que sabe hacer
esto va a acabar con nosotros se va a
revelar contra nosotros
si es verdad que tenemos entre manos una
herramienta muy potente igual que me das
igual que amazon nadie puede asegurarnos
cuál va a ser el futuro de la
inteligencia artificial a muy largo
plazo pero si queremos ser nosotros los
que llevemos las riendas de ese camino
no podemos tener miedo a estas
tecnologías a la inteligencia artificial
sino que tenemos que construir una
relación sana basada en una comunicación
efectiva y que nos falta para esa
comunicación efectiva un lenguaje que
verdaderamente sea textual
porque nosotros somos inteligentes somos
capaces de bajar al nivel textual pero
un ordenador jamás lo haremos contextual
entonces tenemos que buscar este
lenguaje que sea universal que un
símbolo signifique exactamente lo mismo
estemos donde estemos hablemos con quien
hablemos que no depende del contexto o
sea que sea un lenguaje perfectamente
textual
y no se encontraron un idioma tan un
lenguaje tan complejo y encima tener que
aprender de cero poco complicado
pues la buena noticia es que llevamos
mucho tiempo utilizando un lenguaje que
es puramente textual que encima es uno
de los lenguajes más hablados a nivel
internacional
y que cumple todas estas características
que necesitamos cualquier
el ruso el chino
el lingote
estamos hablando de las matemáticas las
matemáticas son un lenguaje son un
lenguaje textual y universal estas
cuatro líneas que tengo a mis espaldas
son las ecuaciones de maxwell y
describen cómo funciona un coche
eléctrico porque las centrales eólicas
son las centrales térmicas generan
energía y la podemos almacenar en
energía eléctrica como se carga tu móvil
todo eso y muchísimo más lo explican
estas cuatro líneas pero lo mejor es que
entiendo lo mismo yo aquí que un
estudiante en japon que alguien en hawai
porque es un lenguaje puramente textual
y esto es lo que necesitamos para
comunicarnos con las máquinas
si le tenemos miedo a la inteligencia
artificial nos vamos a perder muchas
cosas
porque es la incertidumbre la que genera
el miedo y si queremos disfrutar de la
naturaleza de la inteligencia artificial
de las nuevas tecnologías
necesitamos un lenguaje
que nos ayude comprenderlas necesitamos
el lenguaje en el que hable así que
usemos las matemáticas para abrir esta
caja negra que es un ordenador quien de
aquí tiene un ordenador todo el mundo
quien usa un ordenador a diario un móvil
todos tenemos los archivos todos tenemos
música redes sociales internet
cuántas de aquí podrías decirme que sabe
cómo funciona un ordenador
pero luego tenemos miedo de que nos
roben los datos o de que nos espíen a
través del móvil o de qué
sabemos acaso si es posible hacer eso y
si es posible sabemos pararlo
es la incertidumbre la que genera ese
miedo así que
no debemos tener este miedo a las
inteligencias artificiales a las nuevas
tecnologías porque cuando tenemos miedo
huimos y no tenemos el derecho de privar
a las nuevas generaciones de este tipo
de herramientas y sobre todo cuando
tenemos miedo luchamos y es razonable
crear un enemigo que puede ser más
poderoso que nosotros
son las matemáticas el lenguaje que
necesitamos para poder entender a la
tecnología y comunicarnos de manera sana
y solo una sociedad que de verdad entera
se comunique a través de las matemáticas
con la tecnología será capaz de vivir de
manera civilizada una sociedad mejora
cuando sus estándares se hacen más
exigentes
y ya conseguimos estandarizar la lectura
y la escritura podremos hacer lo mismo
con las matemáticas yo creo que si
vosotros
[Aplausos]